- [Instructor] In this video,
we're going to talk about
the quantity theory of
money which is based
on what is known as the
equation of exchange
and it tries to relate
the money supply, M,
so this is some measure
of the money supply,
with the real GDP, Y,
so that is real GDP,
and the price level, P,
so this is price level,
and we'll try to make
this tangible in a second,
and then it also introduces this idea
of the velocity of money
which is a measure of how
much that money supply
is how quickly is it circulating.
If there's a dollar out
there, how many times per year
is it actually changing hands?
Velocity of money.
And the equation of exchange that is used
in the quantity theory of money
relates these as following,
that the money supply
times the velocity of money
is equal to
your price level
times your real GDP.
And we can view this on a per year basis.
So let's make this a little bit tangible.
And actually, let's
try to make it tangible
by making velocity tangible.
Let's say we are in a world where
we have whatever we're using for M,
whatever measure of our money supply,
let's say it says that we have 10 billion,
it's a relatively small economy,
that is our money supply.
And let's say that our real
GDP in this economy this year
is going to be a 100 billion,
I'll just call it per year,
and let's say the price level,
and this is usually some
type of index, this is 1.1
so one way to think about it,
if you take your price level
times your real GDP, so
if you take this product
right over here, that's gonna
give you your nominal GDP
where if this was 1.0,
that would be in reference
to some year that you
consider your base year.
So, this would be your real
GDP in terms of that base year
and then you would multiply
it times this right over here
to get your nominal GDP.
But given this information,
pause this video
and try to figure out what
the velocity of money would be
for that year.
Well, this is relatively
straightforward algebra.
To solve for V, we just
divide both sides by M
and we would get that our
velocity of money in this year
is equal to our price
level times our real GDP
divided by our amount of money.
And so, this is going to be equal to,
we have 1.1
times 100 billion,
100 billion dollars per year,
divided by 10 billion dollars.
So, what is this going to be?
1.1 times a 100 is a
110 divided by 10 is 11.
So we are going to get, this
is going to be equal to 11.
The dollar units would actually cancel out
and all you're left with if you tried
to look at the units is 11 times per year.
And so, one way of interpreting this
is for these numbers, your average dollar
is going to circulate 11 times per year.
If this idea still seems
too abstract to you,
think of it this way.
Let's have an extreme economy
where we only have two parties
and let's assume that our price
level is just a simple one,
in which case, our real
GDP would be the same
as our nominal GDP, and let's say
that our GDP this year
is 100 billion dollars,
100 billion dollars per year,
and let's take an extreme situation where
the amount of money that we have
is also 100 billion.
Well, this would be a world,
if there's only two people
in this economy, or maybe this person
just pays that person 100 billion dollars
in order to get that much worth of output.
And so, every dollar has
just switched hand once.
So the velocity of
money in this situation,
it would be just one time per year.
But imagine another scenario where
instead of M being equal
to a 100 billion dollars,
imagine a situation
where M is equal to $1,
where there's only $1 there.
You could still have a
GDP of 100 billion dollars
because that $1 could just switch hands
a 100 billion times.
It would have to happen quite rapidly
for a dollar happened in the year,
but this person could buy a dollar's worth
of goods and services from this person
and that person buys a dollar's worth
of goods and services from that person
and it would go back and
forth 100 billions times.
And so, in this situation
where you still have
the same real, and actually nominal, GDP,
if your amount of money is
one-one hundred billionth,
then your velocity would have to be
a 100 billion times higher.
Now, the folks who like to think about
this equation of exchange and
the quantity theory of money,
they're often known as monetarists,
and monetarists believe that inflation
is fundamentally a monetary phenomenon,
that if you increase the money supply,
that that's going to lead
to increased inflation
and if you decrease the money supply,
that might slow inflation
or even result in deflation.
So if you want to think about
inflation in terms of money,
we could solve for P from this equation.
So to solve for P, we would
just divide both sides
by our real GDP, and so you would get,
your price level is equal
to the amount of money
times your velocity,
divided by real GDP.
And these monetarists
will assume that velocity
is constant, although folks theorize
that maybe it's not constant,
that technology for example, might make it
a little bit easier to transact
which might make velocity increase.
There could also be a world
where just people's mindsets
make them wanna transact more or less
which could change velocity.
But monetarists tend to
assume that this is constant
because it frankly allows
you to make conclusions
from this equation of exchange.
And monetarists also assume
that changes in the money supply
will not have an impact on
real output in the long run.
So, not impacted
by M in the long-run.
Well, if you assume that these two things
are relatively constant,
well then, you will see
this direct relationship
between your price level
and the quantity of money.
Now in practice, this is likely to be
an oversimplification like
most of our economics models.
For example, coming out of the
last recession of 2008-2009,
the federal reserve
practiced quantitative easing
where they dramatically
increased the money supply
right over here, but we
did not see a commensurate
dramatic increase in
inflation, in the price level.
Now, some folks could argue
that when the federal reserve
in 2008 dramatically
increased the money supply
without a dramatic
increase in price levels,
it might've been because the
velocity of money went down,
that people weren't actually transacting
with all of that money
that was being injected
into the system.
Who knows?
And if you're always able to use velocity
as a bit of a fudge factor, well then
it puts into debate of
how useful this might be.
But needless to say, it
is an interesting model
to at least think about,
that if the money supply
were to increase dramatically
and people transact
at roughly the same rate,
but the actual output
that the economy is
producing isn't changing,
it makes some level of common sense
that maybe that would increase
increase the price level.
You would have more money
chasing the same output.